please welcome our host mr. Eddie Murphy
he dropped out of this one temperature
or do it hey what do we have hail again
please welcome our host mr. Ted bellacor
yeah well it could be worse weird part
is I just got a text message from
Charlie Sheen so what do you think of me
now thank you thank you nannies they
touch our lives in so many ways and
tonight reasontv acknowledges those
who've devoted their lives to minding
other people's business the nominees for
nanny of the year are Kevin real kowski
city planner from Oak Park Michigan who
threatened a woman with 93 days behind
bars for planting vegetables in her
front yard mr. ruhle kowski couldn't be
here tonight due to a prior engagement
new york state senator carl kruger who
proposed a bill that would make it
illegal to cross the street while using
an ipod or other electronic device
senator Krueger recently pled guilty to
federal corruption charges and couldn't
be with us tonight Lewis Fletcher
michigan state senator roger kahn whose
so-called hot for teacher bill would
make most any kind of teacher student
sex of felony even if the student is
older than 18 thanks to con would
finally be able to put a 35 year old
adult education teacher into prison for
getting smoochy with her 35 year old
student because remember it's not the
age that matters but the fact that the
teacher is in a position of authority
and the nanny goes to senator Roger Kahn
this is Senator cons first nomination
and award senator con couldn't be here
to accept the award but he wanted
everyone to know that a federal version
of his bill was recently signed into law
and every producer in this room is under
arrest hands on your head Weinstein